hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing Harry
Potter and you guessed it Hogwarts
Legacy most importantly however we're
going to be looking at where these two
worlds diverge tackling the question of
whether or not Hogwarts Legacy should be
considered a genuine part of Harry
Potter Canon what is Canon but now many
of you may be asking yourselves what
exactly is Canon and what prior content
has been published Under The Wizarding
World label vids this description in
order to set the stage I feel that this
needs to be appropriately defined in the
context of fictional Works Canon refers
to a collection of works that are
considered to be authentic and produced
by the original author or authors of a
particular series or Universe the
concept of Canon in fiction is important
in establishing and understanding the
boundaries of a particular universe or
series and the extent to which works are
considered to be part of that Universe
simply put if it wasn't written and or
endorsed by the original author or
creator of said work then it must be
considered separately from that main
body of work anyone could write a book
about Harry Potter but that wouldn't
make it Canon it would just make it fan
fiction however there are a few
loopholes here with regards to
publication prior to the release of
Hogwarts Legacy the following books and
films were responsible for establishing
the existing Canon I've attempted to put
them in order of canonicality number one
the main Harry Potter novels the seven
Harry Potter novels written by JK
Rowling and published between 1997 and
2007 are considered to be the core of
Harry Potter Canon 2. the movies the
eight Harry Potter films Philosopher's
Stone through tethyala's part 2 are
considered by most to adequately fit the
definition of Canon they were endorsed
by the author and bit into the framework
of the novels so it's hard to complain
too much the only gripes that some may
have with the films is that they
sometimes contradict the books which
should ultimately be considered core
Canon 3. Fantastic Beasts the Fantastic
Beasts films Fantastic Beasts and Where
to Find Them the crimes of Grindelwald
and the secrets of Dumbledore serve as
prequels to the Harry Potter story and
should be treated as Canon these
screenplays were written by JK Rowling
herself and that fact alone serves as
irrefutable evidence that these films
are in fact canonical 4. cursed child
here's where things get a little shaky
the cursed child is a stage play based
on an original story by JK Rowling Jack
Thorne and John Tiffany it is the eighth
story in the Harry Potter series and is
set 19 years after the events of the
final novel Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows the play follows the adventures
of Harry Potter's son Albus Severus
Potter and his friend Scorpius Malfoy as
they navigate the challenges of being
the children of two of the most famous
Wizards in history many deny the cursed
child Canon status for the following
reasons one it's a play not a novel two
it wasn't solely written by JK Rowling
because the story wasn't written
exclusively by Rowling and was instead
co-written by John Tiffany and Jack
Thorne many view the story of the cursed
child as something entirely separate
from Harry Potter Canon 3. it
contradicts Canon because aspects of the
cursed child are inconsistent with the
original series like Voldemort having a
child many view the story as glorified
fan fiction denying it Canon status
5. most games since the Harry Potter
books films came out there have been
countless Harry Potter games released
across a ton of different platforms most
of these games however were lacking they
didn't have the story they didn't have
the playability and they were totally
inconsistent with regards to existing
Harry Potter Canon I think that Hogwarts
Legacy and all of the incredible content
it introduces is the only Harry Potter
game that's even a part of this Canon
conversation but with all of the above
established the question remains was
about Hogwarts Legacy is it Canon and
where would it fit on the above list
briefly catering to those who live under
a rock Hogwarts Legacy is the latest and
greatest Harry Potter game that
introduces us to The Wizarding World in
the 19th century over a century prior to
the events that take place in the Harry
Potter novels it follows the story of
our character a fifth year student at
Hogwarts embarking on his own Journey
Through The Wizarding World exploring
new places interacting new faces and
learning new spells the game boasts an
exceptional level of detail and is
perhaps the greatest thing to happen to
Harry Potter since the original books
films but is it Canon well I think
that's entirely Up For Debate let me
guide you through the arguments for and
against Hogwarts Legacy being Canon
arguments and counterpoints the main
argument and only were the argument for
Hogwarts Legacy not being a part of
Canon is that it was simply not endorsed
by JK Rowling if effectively what this
means is that the game's story and
characters were not created by the
original creator of the Harry Potter
universe and therefore are not an
extended component of the original
fictional world this argument against
Hogwarts Legacy being Canon is quite a
Blow by itself but hear me out for a
second first of all just because Rowling
has repeatedly stated that she isn't
involved it doesn't mean that's actually
the case Rowling has been the target of
considerable scrutiny in recent years
which has led to her gradual
disassociation from content released by
Warner Bros media effectively Warner
Bros media don't want Rowling's current
reputation to harm sales of the game
with that said however I bet she's got
some sort of a hand in how the game was
developed whether she's willing to
publicly admit it or not but second of
all there have been a few Standalone
instances in which content produced by
someone other than the original author
has been considered Canon largely
through a loophole of sorts pertaining
to the company responsible for
publishing said content the Oz series by
L frank Baum is a perfect example of
this official Canon pertaining to the Oz
series is comprised of the primary 14
books written by bomb himself however
there's also the inclusion of the royal
book of Oz which was written by author
Ruth Plumley Thompson after bum's demise
despite the Royal book of ours being
written by another author and after the
death of the original author it still
accepted as Canon due to its
authenticity and authorization by the
original publisher basically in some
instances the endorsement of the
publisher is enough to perpetuate what
can be considered Canon I know this was
news to me too in the case of Hogwarts
Legacy this could be considered a
legitimate argument for the game being
Canon but I do also think it falls on
consumer interpretation
the cursed child is a perfect example of
this technically it's Canon but
sometimes authors Publishers make
mistakes Harry Potter fans will stand
behind the original books 100 but a
screenplay that was only partially
written by Rowling that also happens to
contradict aspects of the story well
that's harder to get behind with all
that said here are some more reasons why
Hogwarts Legacy might be a purer form of
Canon than other more endorsed Harry
Potter releases first of all it doesn't
contradict Canon at least not to a
significant degree I'm still in my first
playthrough but I've been consistently
impressed with how they've managed to
integrate this game into such a complex
Universe full of Rich lore one notable
contradiction to Canon however is that
players are able to obtain the Elder
ones which as we know can be fully
traced back through history on that note
if you want to see the ones full history
then check out my video the bloody story
of the Elder Wand all owners Harry
Potter explained with that said however
I'm willing to accept this minor Cannon
blunder largely due to the fact that
developers and story Builders did an
otherwise amazing job setting the game
in the late 1800s was an ingenious move
as this part of Wizarding history is
close enough to what we already know but
far enough away that there was plenty of
room for them to World build the other
argument which ties into what I said
earlier is that the game is produced by
Warner Bros interactive entertainment's
portkey games which is a subsidiary of
Warner Bros this company specializes in
creating games and mobile apps based on
JK Rowling's Wizarding World and has
direct ties to the official Harry Potter
franchise my last point which is based
solely off of my own opinion is that the
game feels much more Harry Pottery than
anything else released after the
original books and films to me the game
feels more like Harry Potter than
Fantastic Beasts and the cursed child
combined perhaps not everyone shares
that sentiment but that's what I think
in the past I've expressed that Canon
must be written by the original author
but in this instance I'm going to have
to amend my previous statement when I
say that in some cases true Canon can be
influenced by the opinions of fans and
creators affiliated with the franchise
what do you guys think do you think that
Hogwarts Legacy should be considered
true Canon do you agree with my Canon
tier list let me know your thoughts in
the comments below and also be sure to
include any video requests you might
have pertaining to the Wizarding World
as always if you enjoy the content
please remember to like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
foreign